pour ouvrir le passage il faut fumer les
cigarettes
nous sommes maintenant prêts à changer
de monde
mais avant de passer
nous devons demander l'autorisation à
notre Créateur
Emmanuel Macron qui est par ailleurs
pointé du doigt ce matin par le rapport
final d'une commission d'enquête
parlementaire en cause ces liens avec la
société
uber alors qu'il était ministre de
l'Économie ces députés dénoncent je cite
une relation opaque et privilégiée
[Applaudissements]
et notamment un deal secret avec la
plateforme américaine pour qu'elle
renonce à son application controversée
de covoiturage hupper pop cela en
échange d'une simplification des
conditions d'obtention des licences de
chauffeur VTC nous devons donc être
intraitable avec les consommateurs de
drogue et sanctionner plus sévèrement
les conduites addictives au volant c'est
pourquoi nous allons rendre automatique
la suspension du permis en cas de
conduite sous l'emprise de stupéfiants
ça évitera bien des grands malheurs
Stanley consomme occasionnellement du
cannabis mais il l'assure j'ai vu de
conduire sur stupéfiants ça peut être
très dangereux
c'est positif positif
vous pouvez lire dans les cigares bien
sûr que oui
désormais pour pouvoir se promener dans
l'hypersentre de la ville chaque chien
devra se doter d'un passeport génétique
réalisé chez un vétérinaire un fichage
ADN obligatoire qui permettra grâce à
des analyses de sanctionner les promener
un délicat confirme à la limite et qu'on
chope les gens qui l'ont pas fait voilà
mais d'aller faire des recherches quand
même c'est un peu c'est oui je me suis
bien après faut pas exagérer non plus je
suis pas convaincu moi
j'allais te pleurer je te jure si
j'avais pas du Botox mais l'arme elle
coule reste je te jure mais si on est
bien qui est convaincu c'est Robert
Ménard le maire de Béziers avait déjà
tenté d'introduire la mesure en 2016
avant qu'elle ne soit retoquée par la
préfecture mais cette année l'État ne
s'est pas opposé au projet
en Italie en Espagne en Bretagne il y a
plein de mères qui le font parce que
c'est une façon de trouver une solution
à un vrai problème moi j'ai envie que
mes villes soient propres et que les
gens qui viennent profiter en
particulier l'été pas que l'été de ma
ville puisse regarder les façades et ce
qu'il y a à voir plutôt que de regarder
où ils mettent les pieds certaines
rivières déversent emmerdent des
tsunamis de plastique que rien n'arrête
la pollution est inimaginable
la faune se meurt
[Musique]
cette pollution contamine tout
ce que jette les gens par la fenêtre
quand il roule il jette tout ce qu'ils
peuvent par la fenêtre et après ça
s'accumule là avec les flics
mais le plus terrible et que cette
pollution permet à d'autres de survivre
les petites mains de la décharge traque
le moindre au bout de ferraille
[Musique]
et de plastique à revendre recycleur
chauve-souris ouais ok
d'accord
chauve-souris
peut-être que quelqu'un a fait
hypocalypse ici non pas ça
[Applaudissements]
doit fumer 7 cigares chacun apporte une
réponse
le dernier et le plus important
lavez-vous vu
[Musique]
la suite le panneau du hameau de mon cul
qui a une nouvelle fois disparu
était ici il était accroché bien sûr
Boulonnais derrière on avait soudé les
boulons
mais maintenant avec les nouveaux
matériels que l'on a des des matériels à
batterie donc les petites meuleuses vont
très bien ça va super facile à risquer
et donc les gens l'enlèvent très très
vite le chef d'entreprise ne peut vous
interdire d'avoir une relation amoureuse
avec un collègue qu'il y ait un lien
hiérarchique ou non et pour ce qui est
de copuler sur votre lieu de travail pas
de loi mais souvent des règlements
intérieurs consultez-les avant de vous
lancer dans un corps à corps c'est un
conseil
en tout cas le maire justement à une
petite idée du coupable est-ce que c'est
un nostalgique de montcu qui fait une
collection peut-être qu'un jour il
ouvrira un musée avec les panneaux de de
mon cul à l'autre bout de ce lieu-dit
l'autre pancarte et elle toujours en
place et heureusement car ces vols
commence à coûter cher à la mairie c'est
un panneau qui coûte à peu près 120
entre 120 et 150 euros voilà donc on en
remplace en gros deux fois par an deux
fois par an deux à trois fois par an on
le remplace pour les volets plus ou
moins régulièrement nous avons dégonflé
un pneu de votre SUV ne le prenez pas
pour vous c'est votre suivi et tuer le
pollueur donc plus ils connaissent rien
du tout il pense avoir été ciblé à tort
ah bah ça sert à rien parce qu'en plus
c'est une voiture hybride donc ça pollue
pas je suis critère 1 mon critère 1
c'est le top
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le conducteur ne semble pas très
sensible aux arguments des militants
enregistrés sur cette vidéo et peut-être
que à force de dégonflage ça va
entraîner quelque chose de positif mais
ça change rien du tout après en dégonfle
ça va ça va sauver la planète c'est une
action dans le vent ça sert à rien
nous avons réussi